metro investigating reports that a dog
was killed and actually hung from a
fence
by the siegel suites at boulder highway
and u.s 95.
joe moeller now joins us live with more
on this situation joe
brian metro left the scene here just a
few hours ago and they did have that
suspect in back of their
metro patrol units now i did watch as
animal control investigators took
what appeared to be a dog in a plastic
bag away from this spot right outside
the seagull suites right next to this
fence
police say this call came in as a dog
found dead hanging from a fence
a person was taken into custody when i
arrived that individual was in the back
of a police unit now it's unclear when
exactly this all happened here we did
catch up with a
animal rights advocate gina greison who
came out here as soon as she heard about
what happened
in cases like this we see someone get
arrested but we know this goes on
all day every day in backyards across
the las vegas valley
so people please bring your pets inside
metro says their animal cruelty
investigators were dispatched to the
scene here to help with this
investigation
they would not say what type of dog this
was now back out here live a
representative from segal suites was
also out here and said they are furious
about what happened but they did mention
that this happened outside
of their property again one arrest was
made reporting live here in the
southeast valley joe moore
news